I've talked about YouTube drama which I
talk about as little as possible because
honestly the algorithm loves it when I
do that but I do not want that to become
the focus of this
[Laughter]
channel I feel like I jinxed myself with
this
one
[Music]
so Sniper Wolf and also Jack films but
mostly
YouTube so that's the thing I really
didn't want to talk about this I know I
say that often when I do these but the
thing was I was watching it unfold and
on not like continuously because I don't
have the energy for that but I was
checking in on it intermittently see
what was going on and the point at which
I realized oh I do have things to say
about
this was when YouTube announced they
were demonetizing Sniper Wolf but in
order to explain why I have things to
talk about that I got to give context
for what the heck has been going
on because maybe you don't know or maybe
it just helps to
refresh so there are three Prim figures
in all of this two YouTubers and then
YouTube itself YouTube itself is not
going to enter into the story for a
little bit but once I get to them I'm
going to stay on them for a while but
set them aside for right now so let's
start with Sniper Wolf if you're
wondering why I'm doing s like that it's
cuz she put three s's in the darn thing
and that's how I'm going to pronounce it
Sniper Wolf is what is known as a
reaction content Creator there are
various kinds of content on a platform
like YouTube you have um everything from
video essayists you have life vloggers
you have style advice you have all kinds
of things you have practical things
crafting reaction creators on this
platform or any platform they're also
kind of big on Twitch are people who
watch something and react to it now the
nature of that Dynamic can vary greatly
honestly I do a certain amount of
reaction content before the uh sag after
strike which uh is still in effect
people seem to keep thing isn't the
strike over only the writers the actors
are still striking um I uh was doing on
a fairly regular basis trailer reactions
over on my secondary Channel break room
of Geeks subscribe over there if you
haven't already um I've still got other
stuff going up there but I haven't done
trailer reactions in a while cuz I'm
supporting the strike and the union but
they are not in inherently good or bad
but there's a lot of gradation in terms
of what they do and there's a certain
amount of controversy around the very
nature of reaction
content basically what it boils down to
there are people who think all reaction
content is fine there are people who
think reaction content is inherently
making money off of work somebody else
did that you have not paid for because
you're just watching a thing somebody
else made but you get the ad Revenue new
from it and then there's the Middle
where there's a lot of gradation and a
lot of nuance I think at this point most
people unless they have a specific love
or hate for certain uh reaction content
creators there aren't that many on the
far ends generally if you get someone
who either says it's never okay or it's
always okay it's usually because they
are trying to either slam or defend
certain content creators usually
reaction creators most people are going
to fall somewhere in the middle the
generally accepted way to go about this
or at least the things to avoid is you
shouldn't just be sitting there watching
the thing as you play it in its entirity
with your face up in the corner just
reacting I know that you know the word
reaction makes you think oh well that's
all you do well that's not
transformative and that gets into
incredibly questionable issues of
copyright now there's a lot of ins and
outs and Nuance in this there's
questions of well doesn't this give a
boost to the original creators and lots
of creators have said they don't mind
but some have said they do and there's
also the question of like how much is
the reactor adding to it did they show
the entire thing did they say where it
came from originally did they credit the
original Creator are they actually
adding commentary Insight Nuance are
they looking stuff up are they bringing
something new to the table or are they
just sitting there their face in the
corner collecting the money and reaction
content creators run the gamut and even
some will do both there are some
creators who will often add meaningful
con uh commentary or other things but
sometimes but then other times just do
nothing this tends to be more of an
issue with ones who stream on Twitch for
like eight hours at a stretch and they
get up to cook food but they leave
something playing in its entirety but
that's again that's a whole other thing
and I'm not trying to let this
conversation take up the whole of this
video but know that reaction content in
and of itself can be a bit dicey now to
Sniper Wolf herself
she is a reaction content creator who
has sparked no small amount of
controversy partly because a lot of what
she does is Tik Tok reactions and that
means that she is reacting to an awful
lot of content that she did not make
that uh is made by other people and she
often adds nothing and so even within
the realm of an already kind of
controversial end of content
creation even people who are like
there's nothing inherently wrong with
reaction content have a tendency to
point to her and go there's kind of a
problem with what you do though if you
want kind of a breakdown of the issues
with sniper wolves content in particular
that doesn't really touch on the stuff
I'm going to be getting to because it's
a month old uh here's a video I'm going
to recommend from Echo is weird um who
did a pretty thorough explanation of why
Sniper Wolf in particular is
controversial and in particular her
issues with Jack films who now let's him
in now Jack films is a content creator
does a lot of Comedy based stuff a lot
of skit stuff has been around on YouTube
for a very long time almost from the
start of this platform and he has taken
issue with sniper Wolf's style of
reaction a lot and very very V vocally
basically there's been kind of an
ongoing beef between the two of them
with him criticizing what she does and
her trolling him in various ways um now
I know I kind of brought up the issue of
copyright if you're thinking well
shouldn't she just be getting shut down
if if it is as blatant as people say
like she's uploading the whole thing
it's unaltered she's not commentating
why isn't she running a file of
copyright that has a bit more to do with
YouTube but I'll touch on it quickly
here um in case just so I don't forget
to bring it up later what the issue
there is is that while YouTube has a
copyright claim system a claim has to
actually be made by the copyright holder
of the work in involved and so it's not
strictly speaking YouTube's
responsibility to prevent copyright from
happening it is their responsibility to
do something about it when somebody
makes a copyright claim the problem is
that while somebody any of the people
who have had their stuff reacted to by
Sniper Wolf could put in a copyright
claim and request that the video be
taken down be blocked or that they start
collecting the revenue because it's
their work the issue becomes that if she
disputes that she can take it to court
would she ever I don't know but as I
said she reacts to a lot of ticktockers
a lot of creators who are not making
massive amounts of money a lot of people
who do this for fun people who either
don't have the uh investment in what
they do to take it to court or even if
they do can't afford to do
so so this is something I'll be
revisiting uh justice is for people with
money
and people with money don't have to face
Justice hold on to that thought we'll be
coming back to it but getting back to
Jack's films he's been criticizing her
for a while and on
Instagram oh I forget a week two weeks
ago I've lost track of it time has no
meaning anymore but Sniper Wolf on her
Instagram she put up a thing saying like
hey I'm filming just 5 minutes from Jack
film's house should I go and say Hi and
then soon after put up an image of his
front
door and so Jax films called her out as
having doxed him now doxing uh if you're
not familiar with that term you probably
are but let's cover it real quick is
revealing uh personal information in
particular things like full name and
address or personal phone numbers of
people who have not made that uh stuff
freely available to the public or who
otherwise like that's not public
knowledge where they live and you've
just told the freaking internet and
especially when it comes to any
influencer of size getting docks is
actually a really big deal because yes
there's the obvious things of people who
don't like you showing up and
threatening you but like even your fans
you don't want people just showing up at
your house it's a really big problem in
some areas it is in fact a
crime so Jack films basically started
calling on YouTube to do something about
this because doxing is in violation of
YouTube's um guidelines now if I were to
guess it's possible maybe part of the
reason YouTube didn't act right away
they did act eventually I'll get to it
maybe part of the reason YouTube didn't
act right away is because the doxing
didn't happen on their platform but
their platform is what she's big on so
it shouldn't really matter it's one of
those things like yeah look this person
has done this really bad thing are you
sure you want to keep employing them
even though they didn't do it on company
time kind of that sort of thing so
YouTube did eventually take action now I
know there's been some discussion and
some like odd things like there was a
thing that Sniper Wolf put out where she
was like like his address is publicly
available anyway and when I looked into
that it looked like there is or at least
was at some point it's hard to verify
because if this was the case it was
changed Andor fixed but it looks like
there was an address that was publicly
searchable for JA films
LLC which may or may not have been his
personal address and that was uh
something searchable like you had to dig
around you had to like find the company
listing on LinkedIn or things like that
but that information does not appear to
be there any longer and even if it
was just the fact that like people could
have found this yeah but it wasn't
freely available on one of the biggest
social media platforms on the goddamn
Planet that's still
doxing so even if that was the case what
she did is still messed up and I want to
kind of get out of the weeds of all this
because again the specifics of
this are not really what I'm here to
talk about it's background it's
necessary background I want to talk
about YouTube CU YouTube did eventually
take
action and I'm going to quote them what
they said in a reply actually to one of
Jax film's tweets demanding action
confirming Sniper Wolf has received a
temporary monetization suspension per
Creator responsibilities policy
off-platform actions that put others
personal safety at risk harm our
community and the behavior on both sides
isn't what we want on YouTube hoping
everyone helps move this convo to a
better place oh I bet you are hoping
that YouTube but you made two big
mistakes arguably three for the fact
that this action was not as Swift as a
lot of people think it should have been
but let's set that one aside because you
know bureaucracy demonetizing somebody
especially somebody big and notable is a
pretty big thing so maybe they took a
little bit of time to get advice Maybe
even run it by legal things like that so
like while I'm not going to say it's
okay that they didn't act sooner I'm
going to let the delay in action go for
the time being in this case I'm not
saying you have to let it go I'm saying
for my P purposes I'm going to let it go
so that means they did two
things that are a big
problem
one they freely announced that the
demonetization of sniper Wolf's channel
is
temporary they set it right up front not
conditional cuz conditional would have
been we're demonetizing it and if she
can comply with X Y and Z she'll get it
back that would be conditional no just
temporary just saying up front this will
lift with
time so you're saying flat out that all
she has to do is
wait
secondly both
sides now look again I don't want to get
bogged down into the weeds of whether or
not Jax films or fans of Jax films were
harassing of the YouTube support team or
other things honestly I could kind of
believe that they were but like the both
sides that YouTube should actually care
about are Jax films and Sniper
Wolf the worst he was doing was
demanding action at least so far as what
I could find so why what are you both
siding
here's the
thing
YouTube does not know how to call Bad
actors off its platform it doesn't it
almost never boots anybody entirely
there are the rare exceptions Alex Jones
one of the bigger ones but for the most
part the actions that YouTube takes
against creators who have flatly
violated the rules but are big
enough is
insufficient and insulting to be honest
because this is not just Sniper Wolf
YouTube's been pulling this nonsense for
a long time Logan Paul PewDiePie Matt
Walsh all of them and many more have had
their monetization suspended and it is
always temporary and more point it is
always temporary and that lifting is
pretty much unconditional they wait a
certain amount of time until they think
everything's blown over and then YouTube
says here you can start making money
again now there's some of the uh odd
specifics in the case of sniper wolves
such as the fact that some folks
snooping around have uncovered evidence
that it looks like only her new uploads
are being demonetized not any of the old
stuff on the channel That still gets to
generate Revenue same as any any other
time now granted the highest revenue Vue
income for someone like Sniper Wolf is
going to be on newly released stuff but
she's still pulling in money it looks
like from the old stuff so it was a
partial demone demonetization and you
set up front it was temporary the thing
is though I almost kind of respect the
fact that they set up front that it was
temporary CU at least they're not trying
to hide the fact that this is a slap on
the wrist and was never going to be more
than that because they've made bigger
deals in the past
with people like Logan Paul with people
like PewDiePie with people like Matt
Walsh but in all those cases eventually
the monetization came back actually
PewDiePie is the one question mark on
that from what I can tell the last time
we got demonetized was December of last
year and I couldn't find confirmation
that he was remonetized again but then
that brings us back to the other thing
even if you did permanently demonetize
these channels if you let them continue
to use your platform these people with
millions of sub subscribers they are
still going to make a living doing it
and continue to be able to Bo to do
whatever it is you are trying to punish
them for because you're still giving
them access to an audience as I said I
think PewDiePie might actually still be
demonetized but it doesn't matter he's
got sponsorships for videos he's got
merch he does live streaming elsewhere
he has enough flows of income same with
Matt Walsh he could and moan all
he wanted about getting demonetized but
he's subsidized by the daily wire his
bills are paid already the thing that
you actually have YouTube that you could
actually take away from them that would
actually hurt them is the
platform because the thing is when all
of these have proven temporary and
especially when you say at the front end
that it's going to be temporary what
this ultimately amounts to is a fine
it's a fine over time as opposed to a
set number because you're going going to
remove their ability to make money on at
least new things for a certain amount of
time and however much money that might
have been I don't know could be a little
could be a lot but ultimately what
you're doing is issuing a fine a fine is
only a punishment if someone can't
afford to pay
it these channels with millions of
subscribers and massive payouts for
sponsorships and guest spots elsewhere
and merchandise they can afford it they
don't have to get better and we know
they don't have to get better because
during the time when Matt Walsh was
demonetized and at least he said YouTube
said he had to stop doing certain things
or start doing certain things in terms
of his behavior he didn't obey by any of
that that's assuming that he was being
accurate honestly I don't trust a word
that came out of that guy's mouth it's
distinctly possible that they didn't
give him any specific guidelines but he
continued to do the exact thing that
YouTube said they demon ized him for
while he was
demonetized and he still got his stuff
back he doesn't have to get better he
doesn't have to improve cuz you're going
to give him back what you took it's a
fine he can afford to pay it and so he
doesn't have to
improve nobody's impressed anymore we
all got spooked back in
2018 when the nonsense with Pewdiepie
happened and Logan Paul happened and the
adpocalypse happened and you
restructured all this stuff so people
could not make nearly as much money on
this platform itself and then everybody
sought additional streams of Revenue
they sought the sponsorships they got
patreons they did all this other stuff
they may still need or at the very least
want the income they get from YouTube
directly but that's not their only thing
anymore it hasn't been for a while
because of changes you've already done
and as I said back in 2018 we all
panicked I was here we all panicked when
we saw what happened but what you've
proven since then is that if if you have
over a million subscribers you will get
your monetization back you just will all
you have to do is wait it out that is
what you have proven over and over and
over again and this is honestly a bigger
problem than just YouTube this is
indicative of the inherent problem with
fines as
punishment fines are only a punishment
to people who cannot afford them it's
why parking or speeding tickets for
someone who is broke and was speeding to
try and get to their job that they
desperately need to make their bills
because they're living paycheck to
paycheck that will hurt them a lot
speeding ticket to somebody who makes
$100,000 a year it's an annoyance at
most and it's not going to deter the
behavior why would it now you could try
and argue with me like well that's why
it escalates so many things and you get
your license
suspended that's assuming you get caught
yeah but this is isn't a one: one I'm
just being illustrative you want me to
go more of a one: one I'll give you a
one: one companies when they are fined
in violation of consumer protection laws
they are fined for less than the money
they made by breaking the
rules this has happened with
pharmaceutical companies this has
happened with automobile manufacturers
they continue to break the rules because
the maximum f L that can be placed on
them is less than the money they'll make
by breaking the rules now is that
exactly what's going on with YouTube
where breaking the rules is what's
making the money no not necessarily but
it's got the exact same problem of not
detering Behavior because in the case of
massive corporations why would they
start doing what's in the best interest
of the
consumer they make more money breaking
the rules and then paying the fine
that's if they even get caught so same
thing here if these people want to
behave this way want to say the things
they say do the things they do push the
ideas they push if that's what they care
about and that's what they want to do
making them pay a fine that they can
afford to pay won't stop them doing it
just imagine what it would be like if
you lived in a place where if you robbed
a bank you had to pay a $1,000 fine if
you were found guilty of robbing the
bank but you got to keep all the money
you took from the bank
what do you think would happen everybody
be robbing the damn bank that's the
incentive set created by fines levied
against people who can afford them
YouTube if you actually care about the
Integrity of your platform about
enforcing the rules that you freely
enforce against significantly smaller
creators then you will not simply
demonetize these people you will take
them off the platform you will say this
is not who we are and this is not what
we're about and we don't want it here
but you won't do that because you don't
think that because they have millions of
subscribers and they bring in money
because it's worth noting keep this in
mind demonetizing these people doesn't
mean that no ads play on their videos it
just means they don't get the revenue
from
it YouTube still makes ad revenue on
demonetized videos or at least videos
that were demonetized by them you can
voluntarily have it no monetization and
in
theory in theory there's supposed to be
no ads run on it there have been some
people who have uncovered what look like
instances of YouTube uh manually turning
monetization and ads back on on the back
end which I don't know if I'm
comfortable saying that's a certainty
but I've had my own evidence in the past
of them loading up more ads than were
placed there originally by the creators
I did a whole video on the fact that
they do that nonsense YouTube I know you
don't really care I know that you are
here to make money that's always the cry
in the defense a corporation exists to
make money yeah they do but if you want
to at least
pretend to have standards
pretend to have rules that aren't just
if you are bringing in enough money for
us then we will look the other way then
start
Banning people who break the
rules large channels repeat offenders
but you don't and you won't this
platform is rotten it has been for a
long time why am I still here because
it's a def facto Monopoly I mean it is
the thing is the tech sector is severely
underregulation in general but lawmakers
don't get how this works they look at
the fact that YouTube exists twitch
exists Tik Tok exists and they think oh
there is variety and competition for
video platforms on the internet there
isn't a monopoly there's all these
options except each of those is
effectively a monopoly of a smaller
sliver of it Tik tok's effectively a
monopoly on short form video content
twitch is effectively a monopoly on
streaming yes you can stream on the
other platforms yes you can do short
content on the other platforms but those
are the de facto monopolies for that
YouTube is the de facto Monopoly for
what I do sitting in front of a camera
rambling for I don't know half an hour
or so at a guess this time and then
editing it down and making it
presentable video essay style content or
just edited video content in general
this is the de facto Monopoly
they hold too much power nobody is going
to make them actually enforce their
rules that's the thing that's the
problem when the things that are aren't
supposed to happen are 100% dictated by
company policies because they can ignore
their own rules they wrote them they can
ignore them what's the penalty if
YouTube Just decides to not enforce its
own rules
nothing loss of credibility
okay where else are you going to go for
this kind of content especially if
you're a Creator where else are you
going to put up your stuff now what's
the solution for this I don't
know I'm not necessarily saying it's
going to be laws because no I don't
really want
legislators trying to make these rules
either should there be some kind of
penalty for places failing to uh live up
to their own stated policies and rules
maybe but I'm not a politician I it's
not my job to come up with all the
solutions here that doesn't mean I don't
have a right to point out the freaking
problems yeah Sniper Wolf did something
messed up but
YouTube is the end boss of where all the
problems land it's YouTube that won't do
anything to actually cause people like
her or Logan Paul or PewDiePie or Matt
Walsh to ever change their behavior I
was foolish enough for a hot second to
get excited back when Matt Walsh first
got
demonetized and I saw what he was doing
while he was demonetized I thought
they're not going to give it back to him
he's he's still doing what they
demonetized them
for then they did I don't know why I
thought that wouldn't happen I think I
was just uh enjoying the
Hope Hope's a hell of a drug
man but then I crashed CU reality came
back
in so yeah Sniper Wolf Jack films it's a
mess but it is a uh it's a rotten little
apple out on a
branch of the completely rotten tree
that is YouTube Ain't it Fun
here what are your thoughts about any of
this whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let to talk
about it patreon is my side thing so I'm
not 100% dependent on this platform that
being said that does not fully cover my
bills so I do still need this platform
so help me if they demonetize me in
retaliation no they won't they won't
they don't know who I am I'm small I'm
under a 100,000 I still count as a small
YouTuber they don't care about
me I mean they don't care about me in
the sense that they won't notice me well
they care what I'm saying if they did
notice yeah probably
whatever I'm not trying to be
conspirator like they're going to come
for me like they don't give a crap I'm
not a million plus subscriber channel of
course they don't give a
crap but that's why sometimes you'll see
smaller channels just vanish out of
nowhere anything sub a million
followers can just be snapped out of
existence for violating who knows what
rules and to be fair YouTube is slightly
better than say Tik Tok who will not
even tell you what rules you broke and
then ban your account and then
and then reject your appeal literally
within minutes of you sending it so
there's no way a human being actually
looked at it and do that to you twice I
might have a bone to
pick so YouTube is not the worst at
enforcement of its
rules but it's
bad you could at least
try you could at least not make it very
clear how token this is or the fact that
the only reason you did it was so
everyone would shut up you practic Al
said that at the end of your freaking
thing on Twitter oh and by the way just
as a little cap on this Sniper Wolf did
Issue an apology and claimed to own up
to her actions which she only did after
the demonetization came in which makes
me wonder if that was either a request
and or requirement from YouTube that she
apologized for it or if she's just
trying to play
nice I don't know this has been going on
for a while she could have apologized at
any
time whatever I'm done with this
thoughts in the comments
I'll mention the patreon again I would
have already done the thing up there
Link in the description help me eat and
not be as fully dependent on this
freaking hell
site but what I really want you to
remember despite all this
nonsense you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you're the council and I'm just
running the meetings until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
time to thank some patreon backers and
in the spirit of October I'd like to
thank Robin Moore Zubin L fulla goddess
ala Tac the thing that goes dink in the
anime Ruth Oliver be solitary pictures
or bton Melinda Walters Jen Auntie Kate
808 Becky Sparks falx the BR Robin
Powell Tracy scrapit angry caspel Dave
Hall and Rosalyn
Bennett thank you for your assistance um
I don't know I might try theming the
shout outs in the future I don't know
we'll see thank
[Music]
you
oh